we're now going to introduce the concept
of potential energy let's begin by
considering a system where a
conservative force is acting so I'll
consider a conservative force which I'll
call F sub C and so for such a force the
work integral is path independent so the
work integral for this force is the
integral of F sub C dr. yes which is the
path going from point A to point B and
for a conservative force this integral
does not depend upon the path from A to
B it's independent of a and B so it
depends only upon the endpoints ok so
this is a path independent integral and
since it depends only upon the endpoints
I can write it since it's going to be an
integral from point A to point B this
integral must be equal to some function
of the final point so some function of R
sub B minus some function of the initial
point R sub a can just consist of
integral from A to B and so in our usual
way of evaluating a definite integral
it's going to be equal to some function
of our B minus some function of our a
since C 0 depends only upon the
endpoints now let's call this function
I'm gonna make a sort of funny choice
here so let's call this function minus u
as a function of position vector
position vector R and we'll see the
reason for this funny choice of minus
sign in just a moment
and so now with this definition
my work integral which again is the
integral of F sub C dot DS from point A
to point B is now minus U of RB - minus
U of R a so in other words that's minus
U of R B so minus minus gives me a plus
U of R sub a ok for shorthand I can
write that as minus u sub B plus u sub a
ok and since we start out at Point a and
go to point B notice that I can also
write this as the negative of the change
in U since the final value of U is our
you would be and the initial value is
you would a so this - you'd be + u a is
equal to minus Delta U the change in U
as we go from the initial to the final
position ok and note that in addition to
that I given that this is the work
integral I can summarize that by writing
that so I'll just say note that Delta U
is equal to the negative of the work
done going from point A to point B now
let's write the work kinetic energy
theorem using this newly introduced u
function okay so the work kinetic energy
theorem which tells us that the work
done which we've seen is minus u sub E
Plus u sub a is equal to
the change in kinetic energy Delta K
which I can write as K sub B minus K sub
a or I could also write that as one-half
M VB squared minus one-half M VA squared
so this is just restating that the work
done on the system is equal to the
change in kinetic energy and I can write
the work in terms of my function nu that
I've introduced here to - use of b + u
sub a so I'm going to rearrange this
equation now basically the one involving
use and the one involving kinetic
energies so that I have all the terms
involving a point a on one side and all
the terms involving point B on the other
side so rearranging I get that at Point
a one-half M VA squared + u sub a is
equal to at point B one-half M VB
squared + use of B now notice however
that there's nothing special about how I
chose the points a and B they're
completely arbitrary so that means this
equation must be true for any points a
and B and what that means is that each
side must be equal to the same constant
for any point in the system so in fact
we can write
that K+ you for any point must be equal
to some constant which I'm going to call
e sub mech so K here is the kinetic
energy U is my function that I
introduced and we're going to call it
the potential energy and E sub mech and
remember this east of mech here is a
constant east of mech is something that
we call the total mechanical energy now
what we've done here is that we've shown
to the total mechanical energy which is
the sum of the kinetic energy and the
potential energy is a constant under the
action of a conservative force in other
words if we look at this equation and
look at how it changes with time the
change in the kinetic energy plus the
change in the potential energy is equal
to the change in the total mechanical
energy and this is zero for a
conservative force so in other words the
change in kinetic energy is balanced by
the change in potential energy such that
the sum is zero when the force acting is
conservative now we've now introduced
the very important concept of the
potential energy that is associated with
a conservative force and we see that the
change in the potential energy the way
we defined it the change in the metallic
potential energy is equal to the
negative of the work integral for a
conservative force going from point A to
point B now in fact it's actually only
the
change in the potential energy that has
physical significance will be concerned
with potential energy differences or
changes the actual value of the
potential energy itself doesn't matter
we're free to choose any convenient
reference point or zero point for
measuring the potential energy it's
equivalent to choosing a coordinate
origin when we're talking about
positions now the potential energy
change is related to the work done by
conservative forces but we know that in
general work can also be done by non
conservative forces although that work
by non conservative forces will depend
upon the path taken from point A to
point B so in general the total work is
given by the sum of the conservative
work the work done by conservative
forces which we can relate to a
potential energy change and the non
conservative work done and it's this
total work that tells us what the change
in the kinetic energy is now we'll soon
see that in the presence of non
conservative forces the total mechanical
energy which is K plus U is not a
constant